you know we've arrived at a place  technologically where a single  individual could topple the pillars  technological pillars of civilization  for an entire metropolitan area like  miami or new york or boston just by  himself just with that and if you had it  just with that yeah and if you had a  team of guys running around the country  you could black out the whole national  electric grid just just with these  devices how come it's not happened yet  well  uh it has happened in chechnya and other  places uh it hasn't happened in this  country i'll give them time you know  you know i don't know why it hasn't  happened yet we've been lucky you know  uh uh the great german statesman otto  von bismarck once said you know god  looks after uh  fools drunkards little children in the  united states of america